hi dad when are you coming home sam  listen to me don't be scared all right  that emergency escape plan that we've  been practicing i need you to get out of  that house  everything is gonna be fine  sam is okay  we are okay  [Music]  hi jack where's the boy  boy  i don't need a kid a dog okay  you're gonna be okay i promise are they  gonna get away with killing my family  they're professional killers  i'm gonna come for anyone who tries to  screw jack  if they find you with me they're sure to  kill you  gypsy  you took the kid  who are you hiding from  batman  you serious  you're using that kid  i know you because i'm the guy that  pulled you up from the gutter  i got a chance to change my life i can't  let anything including a kid get in the  way of that  be strong don't quit  for a bowl you can't  not today  that boy's mind gypsy  who killed this book  you